they were going to be talking about
middlegame
plants and how to analyze the position
from a static point of view I'm sure you
guys already heard about static and
dynamic what is a good static position
when your opponent has no counter play
and basically when you can improve your
position slowly yeah what is a bad
static position it's basically when
you're facing that type of advantage
your opponent your opponent is slowly
slowly building a strategic advantage
and you don't have a lot of things to do
so what do you what do you need to
usually try to find whenever you're
facing a bad static position counterplay
right okay there are four criterias when
we're talking about static assessment
number one what do you guys think we
should look for King safety yeah number
two material situation that is pretty
much the second one the third one is how
how will the position look like if we
take the Queen's of the board and the
fourth one is pawn structure so let's
try to make this static assessment of
this position it's black to move by the
way number one King safety who's better
pretty equal I would say yeah but can
you take advantage of that not yeah not
right now at least so for the moment the
King safety is kind of equal what about
material this is the easiest one it's
equal how the position be if we take the
Queen's off the board white is
definitely better yes so we it's black
to move by the way so white would still
be better because the fourth one pawn
structure who's better debatable I would
say white is better because black has a
clear weakness that white is is taking
advantage right now and that is the
weakness on d7 the backwards pawn on d5
and he's just going to put his rook on
the D file and then you're going to have
some some problems defending against
that also his pawn structure right now
in the center it kind of gives him a
space advantage so statically black is
worse yeah all right so when we have
when we have those type of situations
obviously we try to kind of find counter
play destabilize the position a little
bit so what should we do now
what are some options of blacks this
position hmm rock they see three okay
and this is exactly what black played in
this position Luke takes it three all
right let's do the the assessment now
King safety black is much better already
yeah material situation white is doing
much better without the Queen's on the
on the board white would be winning and
pawn structure black is better right so
we kind of equalized those advantages
and which one do you guys think is the
most important of these of your vantage
King safety yes absolutely so despite
the fact that he gave he gave an
exchange he got a lot of counter play in
return what would you guys play hmm
Queen e8
absolutely okay right what are some some
ideas that that white could could
implement in this position what should
he play let's try to calculate a little
bit candidate moves
that's one absolutely roof d3 is the
second one anything else yeah that that
could definitely be be an idea 95 rook
takes e5 so if you goes king of 295 I
would say oh I would say Queenie 4 in
this position is is a little bit better
because we're trying to play rook e8
we're not really in a hurry to to take
this e3 pawn we're actually just trying
to get our pieces out and and kind of
attack the King that way right also with
these Queenie for what else are we
accomplishing hmm can this screen not go
back to c2 and come back to the defense
anymore no so you're kind of restricting
your opponent's Queen as well mm
restriction and then we go to the second
second lesson that we had together
mastering the middle game last week
absolutely so King f2 is not a good move
what else
what waters could try a white try what
about rook d3
Queen c2 is is what he did in the game
but it's probably not the best move he
underestimated the fact that that III
pawn doesn't matter that much that e3
pawn is actually very important because
it protects the King so you do have to
fight for the defense of it I think Luke
d3 would have been the best move in this
position rook d3 and what should we do
now 95 then route d5 94 and then what
ruk d3 back and probably the best thing
black can do as well is is just accept
the draw yeah
the repetition with 95 so route d3 would
have definitely been the best move white
played Queen c2 Queen take citria
mediately Queen takes the tree it's it's
not just about the double point but once
again it's it's about the safety of
White's King and it's definitely damaged
after the loss of that point King h1
continue okay rook e8
maybe I'm going to take this pawn
now I think now that we don't have to
worry about now we have to worry about
the 7 points so why not we just play 95
yeah normal move also it kind of
solidifies the screen on e3 it cannot be
attacked this night only 5 is like super
super strong look at one what now
continue improving your position well he
can but I mean if if he does first of
all he's upon down and his structure is
pretty bad
why structure is pretty bad his King
safety is completely ruined
so I mean black is almost winging in my
opinion here you're not really getting
anything in return right so you kind of
chose your destiny now you have to keep
material as much as possible so he
played the rook F 1 black improved his
position with rukhi a rocket for what
now
what is his threat
rocky for absolutely rocky for maybe one
Queenie for so what should the black do
somebody else not you
hmm
placed all it just guys
Oh suggestions
Oh Niger six is interesting the problem
with 96 I have a feeling you're kind of
getting a bit distracted and this night
is very solid in the center right now if
you play 96 I'm going to go rock f3
and it's it's it's y2 is starting to a
meson sort of initiative right now I'm
not really sure what you're going to do
because you don't want to exchange the
Queen's at least not for the moment not
in this position because if you exchange
I take take and my rooks are very active
right we could consider exchange the
Queen's but we have to keep the rooks in
check like if we allow the routes to
infiltrate then we're going to be in
trouble that's when they are the
strongest and also obviously ninety-five
doesn't work because of route ei yeah so
96 not the right move
candidates
9601 way to defend that night but there
are plenty of other ways
well maybe not plenty ya f6 absolutely
we have to solidify that night right so
why don't we play f6 and not only that
it solidifies the night but it also may
be potentially in an end game we will
have space for our King to to go closer
to the center as fast as possible right
centralization of the of the King
especially in the endgame is is of great
importance
so f6 is a pretty good move I think
Queeny form and now a critical moment of
the game let's try to think about once
again our candidate moves and see
exactly what type of position we are
looking together and and calculate
obviously Knight g4 interesting yeah
Knight g4 Azure is an interesting move
yeah I will take if you go on a g4 I
will take your queen you're going to
have to take with the knight Knight
takes c3 and then I'm going to play rook
takes d7 unfortunately your rooks once
again are getting active yeah I don't
want that I don't want to allow that if
if I enter an endgame I want to keep
your rooks closed you know
nobody's saying Quincy won yeah Quincy I
mean Quincy one is is definitely the
first thing we need to look at right
because it's the check at least right so
let's calculate a little bit Quincy one
kingi - do we have any continuation
and does white have any threats
white is threatening rule d seven
exactly and the queen going to see one I
feel that it actually improved White's
king's position
yeah just the safety has increased a
little bit I mean we can take this pawn
but then after Luke takes d7 once again
his rooks are getting active we don't
want to allow that so Quincey what is
the first thing we need to look to look
at you look you look at it a little bit
you see that you allow his queen to kind
of remain central on e4 and kind of
control the whole position and we
understand that it's not a good move yes
okay ninety-six
that's an interesting candidate could
you elaborate on that mm-hmm well his
pawns are his structure is definitely
bad yeah absolutely but
can he take on d7 well he can but he's
going to lose his his other rook right
so you're kind of getting some speed in
that position in that endgame and you
also infiltrate your with your rook in
the same time you're keeping his rookie
his roots in check he doesn't really
have a way to coordinate them and create
an attack against his King so I think 96
is the right move and that's exactly
what he played 96 Queen takes c3 rook
takes c3 okay now he took on d7 let's
try to hit OB he took on the seven and
he accepted a clearly worse endgame
let's try to look at at other moves and
see if they work or not try to assess
the position in those cases so what
about rook F - sure
I think you already kind of made a
mistake after look after you definitely
once again you don't want to allow him
take only someone I mean there is
absolutely no point in doing that why
would you let his rook enter your
position I mean I'm not saying you might
still be better but it's kind of
pointless to do that so we're going to
play 95 very solid you know slow slow
improvement of the position this point
is not running anywhere we're going to
take it anyway we're going to take on c3
then take on c4 bring the King to the
center and the position is almost
winning right so what about rook f3
let's try to assess that position
because that's I feel the critical
variation rook rook f3 rookie 7 yeah
that's that's an interesting that's an
interesting line but I think after rook
f3 we have to kind of make a decision if
we play rook e7 we're going to have to
admit that our rook is not going to get
active anytime soon yeah if we take on
it only to the rook is going to be very
free to to create a lot of damage to
White's position but there is a
continuation of the rookie to that I I
need you guys to a follow up rookie to
route xd7
well if you it's a good question yeah so
rook takes it to room takes D 795 rookie
7 rookie 1 check King G 2 and then we
just take the rook because the rock only
one is protected yeah
so after up Texas 795 what do we
accomplish with this move
so after this after rook e7 once again
I'm going to show it for everybody to
see we had to give this check so that we
put the rope on a defended square yeah
what if he goes Rudy a king of seven how
is this position what did we accomplish
by attacking those that work and forcing
her to to go to DA he cannot take any
points and and your king is free right
now yeah if if the rook would have
stayed on the seventh rank then there
would have been a lot of possibilities
of connecting the rooks and maybe trying
to checkmate you in a way right with the
rook Ando on the eighth rank that's not
going to be possible any time soon and
this is if you look a little bit at the
position is completely winning for for
black for various reasons he has to go
on he has to go on f1 we take on a a -
how is this king
in here yeah you can play rocket for no
problem is the same thing I would still
take this pong I the night is going to
stay here the night is central the night
has a very very solid position I don't
want to move it anywhere at least not
for the moment at least not if you try
to try to do something extraordinary the
problem is your route is completely
paralyzed if it moves anywhere on h4
night-night f3 is coming and your king
is almost checkmated yeah so that's the
problem this night keeps this routine
check sorry T time T time it's my alarm
for tea time I don't know why it's a
yeah
anyway black is completely winning right
so seeing these hold these variations in
he said why decided to just take on
these 7 and and try his luck in this end
game but this is already lost yeah we
how is how is the structure its equal
points but the structure is clearly in
our favor
yeah what should we do now which pawn
should we take
he decided to take the pond on e 2 and I
think is the right decision because if
you allow these points to stay connected
they will be able to defend each other
yeah these two ponds are anyway very
very weak so he decided to take this guy
and then this guy so rook takes it to
Luke they say seven rook F to root B 7
root takes c4 root B 3 what to do now
hmm
yeah ruh k4 could be an idea but the
rook if we play Roque for the problem is
he's going to go Ruby five and at least
right now his rook is kind of getting a
little bit more active so always try to
be super precise the rock on c4 is
keeping this rook stuck on b3 right why
would we move it he doesn't threaten to
play a five he's not threatening to put
his roof behind his pawn and and start
pushing it so he decided to just bring
his King to the center yeah usually the
usual thing you need to do in in end
games King G to g5 King at three we
bring the King to the center row k3h
five now we just push the pawns there's
nothing really that white can do once
again his his pieces are very very
passive yeah and that's one of the most
important things in rookin games
activity versus passive pieces yeah try
to have the active pieces all the time
okay six skinny five a four C for oxy
six take and I don't know why he's not
resigning he's a he's a resilient man
who takes e4 rook e8 and
the rope house here is pretty obvious
that the pawns are going to promote very
very quickly okay that was the first
example let's see the second example
which is a little bit more difficult
you're going to be white give it some
time because it's not easy at all once
again let's make the static assessment
of the position King safety equal sure
yeah
around equal material hmm equal yeah how
is the position without the Queen's on
the board hmm who black is definitely
better yeah black is definitely better
because he has the fourth the fourth
criteria at the pawn structure black is
much better yeah it's not necessarily
about what happens immediately from a
static point of view on the long run
you're going to be in big trouble
because of your pawn structure because
maybe because of this square yeah this
Knight can go to c4 very nice once again
you have this backward pawn quite a
liability in this position yeah
so we're not doing very well from a
static point of view we have to kind of
change the dynamics of the position the
character of the position so try give it
up give it some thought a few minutes
maybe one two minutes give me some
candidate moves and we will start
analyzing them somebody said something
else
CSC four and that kind of makes sense
right c4 Bishop c1 Queen takes you one
once again let's make the static
assessment of the position King safety
who's ahead white white is ahead because
right now this queen is coming to h6
what are you lacking with black your
dark square bishop yeah you have you
have some some big problems because of
that and potentially if this pawn goes
to d5 this bishop will open up and then
once again you're going to your king is
going to feel very very bad he is going
to be in big danger so that's clearly in
White's favor material black obviously
without the Queen's house the position
without the Queen's black is definitely
much better and the pawn structure hmm
black is better but so that's three
advantages to one right white white is
still not doing very well but which one
was the most important of the advantages
King safety right and that's in whites
that's in White's favor so yeah I may be
the computer will find a defense but
practically from a human perspective is
very very difficult to play this
position as black and everything else
white would have been completely lost
from a strategic point of view so when
you have that choice to make don't
choose a passive position just because
it might last longer yeah choose choose
the active field with counter play
option yeah so he played King g7
that's that's where you you forget about
certain things if you play queen g6 2594
would be an option but even stronger
than that would be to play f6 in this
position because this is not a weakness
this is actually an improvement of
blacks position
you cannot take advantage of the light
squares that have just been weakened and
and in fact I'm actually strengthening
all of the dark squares around my King
with this move simple move f6 especially
keeping this square your Knights are
never going to be able to jump there and
also right now even if you manage to
like somehow open the position with d5
your Bishop is not going to be that
strong right because he's blocked by df6
pawn so Queen g5 actually helps black
it's it looks appealing it definitely
looks like you're getting closer the
King but once you realize that f6 is not
really a weakness for him it just
becomes clear that Queen g5 is not right
something else that's not the piece that
we want to improve
Knight c3 interesting nice D 3 I'm going
to take on c4
I think I'm going to take with the Queen
because I want to create some some
attack on this side
right but now okay let's say you play
Bishop g2 right or something like that
but the position changed you you
exchanged one of your main attackers
that night that central knight on e4 and
in in return you actually centralize my
queen we exchanged a few pieces which
clearly favors black so once we
sacrifice once we choose the path of
counterplay we cannot really look back
and try to play safe moves you know you
have to always go for the initiative you
have to kind of improve your pieces in a
decisive way you know you you you you
cannot you cannot give your opponent any
breathing time so 93 would be would be a
bad decision that night only four is is
central is he has the potential of
helping the attack we don't want to move
it back let's try to go to improve to
improve our pieces in order to take
advantage of his holes in the position
his weaknesses in the position rook III
wow that's a
interesting one I will I think I might
be able to take it why I know but it's
it's it's a serious question actually
I'm not sure if I want to take it
because then he's going to open up with
d5 so but I cannot say no to material
I'm going to take it
I cannot say no I'm a greedy grandmaster
as as they usually come take with what
no I'm going I think I'm going to take
these guys well or maybe I should no no
no no no right now I'm going to take
this this knife definitely I'm
simplifying the position and I have a
lot of material advantage so if you
don't check made me right now it's
already a bit too much yeah you gave a
bit too much material so rookie also
rookie three doesn't really create an
immediate plan and it also obstructs
your queen
yeah you want this diagonal ready for
the Queen to jump into the attack h4
let's go I'm not sure about that h4 I
would take on c4 once again
I mean Noah h4 is is a very common way
of actually kind of pretending you are
doing it something but in fact you're
not doing anything so sometimes
sometimes depending on your opponent
they might be getting scared but I'm not
going to get scared I'm going to take on
c4 and I think you're having some
problems now h4 not fast enough
what's the idea
95 95 is an interesting move but you
have to tell me the idea mmm yes yes 95
has a clear attacking idea not only that
you centralize your night but you're
also getting ready to go to g4 and then
bring your queen into the attack yeah so
I mean this should be your first
instinct just because it centralizes the
night and just because you see that that
night is not really doing much on f3 at
the moment so try to redirect your
weaker pieces your pieces that can be
improved I think this is a rule coined
by some some Russian Grandmaster with
difficult name to pronounce I don't
remember is it just take my word for it
I guess so 95 what should black do
what if it takes on c4 let's calculate
let's calculate this hmm
right but no it was defended also in
previous variation right but when the
thing is that I want to take advantage
of the pain right so it doesn't matter
how many times the denied is defended
after you take I'm going to play b5 and
now you cannot move that piece because
you would lose your queen but maybe we
have some extra options now what could
those be let's go let's calculate a
little bit yeah 94 continue with our
plan
attacking queen h6 right so let's let's
take this piece away Queen h6
King g8 or King h8 I don't know if it
matters Knight g5 this the pieces are
starting to become extremely extremely
dominant on the kingside I think it's
just checkmate in me in the next two
moves yeah
there is absolutely no defense this this
kind of setup against the king without
without the dark square Bishop is
extremely extremely dangerous okay so
that's that's another reason why ninety
five is good because Knight takes e4
simply is eliminated it's out of the
question
so what should black do
what if I tell you black is might
actually be better in this position
no I black did resign in just a few
moves but here he is still having the
grip over over the position but he has
to be very careful
h5 is an interesting move but that
weakens weakens your position a lot so I
might be able okay now I'm just going to
put my Queen here
f6 doesn't work anymore because one of
the consequences of you playing h5 is
that you don't defend the g6 pawn
anymore
so now after f6 I just simply can take
the thing with Queen g5 is is I simply
just want to take my queen out of the
pin out of the C file and force you to
move this Knight
because that's the next step of me
building an attack I need to open up
this bishop so after Queen g5 Knight f6
I'm going to go d5 and I think I think
the position is starting to look very
very uncomfortable for you you're still
having some material advantage but what
can you play
what would you play with black just try
to continue the game a little bit let's
say you go and work a kingi get out of
your of the of the diagonal of the long
diagonal 9x g6 exactly F take g6 now you
see once again the point the lack of the
pawn on h7 is is is very very important
Queen takes a queen h7 checkmate next
move because of the pin on the knight
the knight cannot really defend the H
7.0 dh7
square so h5 is probably not a good move
something else I think I've heard it
already f6 absolutely absolutely f6
would have been the best move in the
position
I think there's only there might be only
one moving this position f5
that's a terrible move I mean come on f5
f5 you're you're doing what you don't
want to do you you're weakening the dark
squares why are you going like piece
hunting I mean I
I'm going to go piece hunting I'm going
to go for your king now and you're going
to resign very fast I mean you already
have material advantage your only
concern should be your king right as
long as you manage to get that King to
safety I mean you're going to be winning
but it's not that easy getting that King
to safety is definitely not that easy
let's calculate Knight takes e4
absolutely let's calculate Knight takes
e4 you still have the pin by the same
problem remains Queen h6 check
intermediate check and then my Bishop
escapes yeah and then your your down
material your your having some serious
problems so keep that idea in mind but
tune it up a little bit make it work
I will still go Queen h6 the problem is
that you're living this pond behind and
I don't know if ei tis safety I don't
think it is because my my pieces are
still clogged clogged up against here
against your king
so King f7 is an interesting tribe but
once again not the precise moved
King g8 so one thing we do when we have
this type of super dynamic super super
precise position look at the most
obvious continuation and if that doesn't
work try to change the move order yeah
and that's what that's exactly what
black does King g8 the screen h6 work
it doesn't look like it's working that
well anymore because now you can take
the night on c4 right now the pawn is
not it is not protected so this is a
very very complicated positions position
there are some a lot of a lot of
complications black is probably slightly
better but from a practical point of
view white still has a lot of chances of
delivering that that mating attack so f6
would definitely have been the best move
for black in this position he played
Knight to f6 what to do
which one absolutely d5 immediately d5
and I'm not really sure what black
missed in this position allowing me to
open up my last my last attacker this
super strong bishop on g2 is simply a
deadly mistake
h5 I think we already had this position
on the board right coming from h5 25 was
probably good enough
he played queen afford the same idea
here just attacking that attacking that
knight on f6 King h7 what now try to
calculate idea
is not such an easy variation the
variation is about five moves deep maybe
something like that so
I'll give you the first one I think
simply taking on f7 f6 is okay so we
took on f6 what now
let's let's calculate that 97 is an
interesting it's an interesting attempt
does it work
so 97 he's going to take that night
that's the critical continuation always
always check your opponent's taking the
material 97 Queen takes d7 Queen takes
f6 rook goes to g8
rookie seven is one way absolutely but
back still survives a little bit after
that you have one move that finishes the
game on the spot because after rookie
seven I'm going to take on his seven
Queen takes e7 and I have two two looks
you're definitely winning because of the
attack on on the long diagonal and my
pieces are very uncoordinated but you
have a much more precise move let's see
rocky seven is definitely is definitely
winning on the spot I think so I think
there is a KO there's a KO over there
route 37 yeah route 37 is the main one
but there's another one probably there
are more than one try to be a bit
creative maybe try to be creative
who said that rope three five what's the
hidden threat of rookie five Bishop d3
and then Rock age five checkmate
yeah and he simply doesn't have he
simply doesn't have a way to defend
against it if you play something like
rook e8 we can actually go rook takes h5
directly Bishop d3 now only move rook d6
and the rook is pinned Queen d7 Queen g7
checkmate pretty easy okay so in middle
game positions guys well whenever you
don't know what to choose from whenever
you think the position is very very
unbalanced try to make this static
assessment and and see exactly where you
stand see if you need to change the
character of the position right if
you're worst from a static static point
of view then you have to look for
imbalances right you have to change the
pawn structure you have to get to the
king right imbalances that's that's
that's the word that you're looking for
whenever you're worse from a static
point of view
whenever you're better you try to avoid
those at all costs right